hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer question from one of my
newsletter reader Stella who was asking
me what programs I might recommend for
her to make money from home if it's
filling out surveys or writing articles
she really wants to make money from her
computer and an internet connection and
what would I advised her to do so Stella
I don't know if I have good news for you
or not here I don't have a
get-rich-quick kind of strategy for you
I don't really think those exist or at
least I haven't found one for myself yet
it's really going to come down to adding
a lot of value so if you can find a
customer where you can add a ton of
value to that's how much you're going to
get paid so the more value can add to
somebody the more you're going to get
paid so is filling out surveys gonna add
a lot of value probably not so you're
not going to make a lot of money that
way writing articles maybe depending on
the type of article and its really good
at writing and you're having a lot of
value then you might get paid well for
that so I wouldn't necessarily start
looking for kind of these get-rich-quick
home business type of ideas I look for a
way that you can add a lot of value to
your customer and then see if that
relates to you know writing articles or
research or whatever it is my other
advice for you here would be to try to
go and target a business if you could
target a business owner and you're
giving them value as a service they're
going to want to hire you back for more
keep giving you more projects you become
an important part of their business you
get repeat business and often much
bigger deals where if you're targeting a
consumer market it's a lot harder to get
repeat business and when it is they're
kind of small chunks it's hard to make a
living off of it so still I don't know
if that helps probably not the news that
you wanted to hear from me on this one
but if you can add a lot of value to
somebody's business then you're gonna be
able to make a lot of money and you can
do that working from home absolutely so
I hope that helps if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up or
leave a comment below I'd love to hear
what you guys have to say it also helps
motivate me to make more of these videos
for you guys so I really appreciate it
when I see those likes and comments
so thank you and stay tuned the next
episode
you